the panic room wants to know when's the
last time you did something for the
first time
if you've never been to an escape room
rocky is at the venetian to show us why
this new flagship
is just the place to escape to all right
we are still trying to escape the zombie
outbreak our team has been working
tirelessly to figure it out okay and one
of the clues i guess out there that they
figured out
unlocked the refrigerator where like
some really
great food is available for you
all right so coming back out here with
our team i hear that you actually found
another really big clue one of the
biggest clues of the zombie outbreak
room right vanessa i think they did
uh oh i'm scared what do you okay so
what are we doing we're turning we're
turning
flipping the breakers yeah we got to
flip certain breakers they found a group
okay
[Applause]
apologize to anyone that just freaked
out sitting at home on your couch wow
okay so the technology is clearly way up
to park here
it is this is intense it's not your
average escape room there's not we have
a lot of moving pieces
it's it's been about a year in progress
of getting everything built here
so we put a lot of work into it and
speaking of that let's talk about the
other rooms here
so we also have our steampunk room we
have
atlantis rising we have the haunted
manor
and we have wizard trials along with
casino heights that we already saw
earlier
okay okay so we have a total of six
rooms okay and how do you guys how did
you guys choose
the rooms you wanted here because
obviously there there are panic escape
rooms across the country
there is so we have 14 different
locations across the country
20 across the whole world right so some
of our rooms are similar
um this is i believe our only zombie
outbreak in atlantis and definitely our
only casino
heist because yeah you know vegas vegas
baby so let's go out because what
what the other part that makes this
location
extra special with a little vegas twist
as we call it
water there's a car there's food there's
drinks and that is not something you get
at your average
escape room so let's come on down this
way
into you already saw where the magic
happens and this is where the party
happens okay
so vanessa where do you guys what do you
guys provide here so we have different
italian food we have paninis we have
bruschetta we have some salads
we got some martinis some specialty
themed drinks here
some amazing manuel italian coffee the
best
okay well listen this is where else can
you have fun at an escape room
go to the bar hang out with your friends
or family or date night
absolutely day night right here in the
venetian so come on down you guys what's
the website again
it's going to be panic escape room.com
and just go to our las vegas location
easy as that i'll send it back to you
i love it rocky's pretty fearless i'm
going to do that i can't believe i
haven't done the escape room yet yeah
but i think
i'm definitely gonna go do that there
ted there i think we should all go as a
group we're talking about christian
and all of us the only thing i want you
guys to know full disclaimer
i'm gonna be of no help just so you know
i'm gonna let you guys take over and
save us all
all right well we'll just keep you
seated okay
i will do the work with our mom i'll be
asleep just so you know i'll be napping
in the panic